Now Matt Oz is running against John
Federman in Pennsylvania he joins us
tonight Dr Oz thank you so much for
coming on so as a non-pennsylvania I
look at this race here's the lieutenant
governor sitting lieutenant governor of
Pennsylvania versus you who's never held
elected office before at all and you're
winning so that suggests to me that
fetterman has done a uniquely bad job
why are these Democrats coming in and
vouching for a guy who can't even win a
race in a state that he's lieutenant
governor of
I think they just want the 51st vote in
the Senate and they don't appreciate
that John fetterman has been unable to
defend his radical abuse and that's the
big issue in this campaign he thinks
these extreme positions that he's held
for years they're out of touch with
Pennsylvania values a good example of
fracking he calls it a stain on
Pennsylvania wanted to have a moratorium
on it had said I'll quote him this is
from just a few years ago I don't
support fracking at all I never have yet
on the debate stage and subsequently he
keeps saying that he's strongly
supportive of fracking but he's unable
to reconcile those and I think what
pennsylvanians are saying which is what
many of Americans can can say on their
own is Washington's getting it wrong
with radical positions I stand for
balance but here's the part there that
gets me the night of the debate
fetterman raised millions of dollars in
order to advance his campaign he's
gotten much more from other Senate
leaders right now that I could have ever
imagined being given to a candidate who
won't explain his radical views so
please help me fight back go to
doctoroz.com this race is going to
ultimately be defined by the ads playing
on both sides I want to be able to tell
the truth about John fetterman more than
he lies about me it's a little unreal
that he keeps attacking you for being
rich which you are but you made your
money this is a guy who lived off his
parents until late middle age who's
never had a real job and he's got rich
kid views he's against fracking like
what do you think rural Pennsylvania has
like how could you be against fracking
in a state that desperately needs energy
Revenue I don't understand that
well that's why he's been flip-flopping
on it but it goes beyond that he's taken
the strong stance to protect criminals
over the desires of the innocent he's
wanted to release a one-third of all
prisoners he argues that if he could
just wave a magic wand that he would get
rid of life sentences for felony murder
he tried to push 25 murderers out of
jail over the desires of other members
of the parole board businesses are
leaving Philadelphia where I am right
now because it's so dangerous and the
Fraternal Order of Police when they
endorsed me it was unanimous because
they just want to do their jobs
yeah and they need to because that City
really is on the brink it's obvious when
you go there I appreciate Dr Oz godspeed
next week
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight